this is my kitchen oh my favorite room
in the house oh no that's her favorite
room in the house
it's got nice coverage
it's like the only thing that looks not
filthy in this whole house
I would love to have this moment
I love to bake and cook
Ed look how hot she is on the ground
it's so deep she looks like she's really
short but she looks super tall to cover
her refrigerator
I am an epic minimalist King
why did you land
I'm just laughing because we're watching
hoarders yeah that's right so today
we're going to look at people the
opposite of Epic minimalist Epic
horrorists
why do you call it epic it's your epic
minimalist epic pescetarian
because it's cringe Ken
okay all right okay fun fact time did
you know the average American household
actually I'm gonna let you guess how
many items do you think is in it
when the whole house yeah
two thousand
higher
higher 20
000 higher no it's not yes yes can yes
well you counting like every Eminem in
the house or something
I know what now I feel like maybe it
messes up what okay I thought it was
fifty thousand I have five you have five
things in your house I actually think
people caught that I had a pair of
slippers they're like ah because I said
I said I only had one pair of shoes it
gets hot in the summer right I have
slippers okay I'm sorry please can I
have at least two please can I have my
epic minimalist license back please
there are 300 000 irms in the average
American yeah I do want to know did he
count the M M's or is that one thing
every cabinet in this house has
something in it every single surface has
something on it you look behind me you
know there's half this stuff isn't even
mine uh you know Einstein's Law equal MC
square right I call this wifey's law any
unoccupied space in your home will
eventually somehow become occupied so
let's watch even though trees are
struggling they're doing better than
mine there so I'm not gonna
okay who's watching who's that I thought
it was a monkey what the what are
you doing over there you ordered me I'm
actually ordering right now before we
continue quick word from sponsor
everyone just clicks away for the ad
portion distract them with your cuteness
it's working we all click click clang on
the internet sometimes you click too
much boom you got hacked Bing Bong you
should have used nordvpn more than VPN
everyone knows nordvpn greatest VPN if
you have any other VPN then you're a
dummy dump maybe there's an ad that pops
up and you click on which then gives you
a malware nordvpn protects you from this
it's got malware protection ransomware
protection DDOS protection protect you
from phishing attacks man in the middle
attacks okay good I need help
okay mommy's back now I can scream
protect you from Scream attacks no way
why live with a constant fear and stress
that something might happen to you that
compromise your security online just
download nordvpn couple bucks a month
you're good to go baby and
obviously I've been using your VPN for
years now and I can say it's fast it's
smooth it connects in just a couple
seconds and it's always running you
wouldn't even notice it keep it on your
phone of course as well whenever you
connect to public Wi-Fi's out in the
public or anything like that it works
amazing it's just a nice way to keep a
peace of mind and also
it's a VPN
so you can watch things from anywhere
around the world you knew that but you
would know that double if you download
it and click on the link in the
description right now with my deal you
get the best deal of nordvpn that is out
every purchase of a two-year plan will
get you a huge discount plus four months
for free and if you're one of those ah I
keep hearing about everybody is every
different thing it's risk-free try it
for 30 days money back guarantee what do
you got to lose check out the link in
the description I highly recommend it if
you haven't already unlock the full
potential of the internet SafeLink
security when you're with nordvpn.com
PewDiePie
Michelle's been sharing that house with
rats I mean rats and rats she's not even
subtle about it just like face straight
up to the fence what do they have like
this prison Security Fence thing right
here so she can't jump it Michelle had
to get it to stop her from stealing her
stuff maybe that's what this is all
about I was told putting red peppers or
unpleasant food hot food along entrances
would help to keep them on their own
side or out of there they're Fearless
they don't run
her neighbors were delighted to hear the
house was purchased by new owners
wait someone bought this house
someone buying this house this is one of
those things where they only show the
outside for some reason in the current
housing market this house probably costs
like a million dollars the first thing
we were thinking we have to connect
a little preview
bro
I think the rat the rats owned this
house like We'll be asking my landlord
if you can buy it you know Master
Splinter what do you think about this
three weeks have passed since the gore
Brothers hired an exterminator to raise
the property oh yes I want this job you
want this job yes but I want them to be
there you know how hoarders get all
defensive if you tell them like I'm
gonna throw all this away and
they're like no I don't need that what
do you do what do you do the hoarder's
like no no this is my trash bags
I might need that toothpick that I've
used five times
I just want to help I would be very
sensitive and courteous about it of
course but on the inside I'll be like
this is awesome
all right Ken you have like scanning
Vision so the thermostat is I don't okay
so first off how high is this trash
because the thermostat you know it's
about ah level for me usually in a house
oh what's at the bottom layer
God
I've been hoarding this is just trash
they just don't crap everywhere I don't
know she might need that
um Old McDonald's burrito bag the old
phone book over there in case you need
to call somebody on the landline I think
before we get into the house I want to
introduce the lady because she is she's
a star she's a star all right
there's some Red Room in the house
yeah and cook and have a friends and
family come she cooks she cooks how
would that the whole place would burn
down if you did anything that is exactly
what needs to happen they just need to
light a match
and I can bake a real nice cake
like steam pack for crab my favorite
what did you wait her crabs
I hope she said crab but at this point I
I don't think it's weird to this even
if you said anything else
it was working but not right now it was
just like yeah the other day somehow
yeah that's why everything's so dirty
she can't clean up the waters
I would have loved to have
um Gourmet Kitchen in the future I say
be not money to remodel it
I was a law student for 10 years from
1986 to 1996.
I didn't take the exam to become
officially
but I did study and prepare for it
in years and 10 years and now they're
collecting rat poop
how do you study for 10 years in years
oh my God
I mean maybe that's just kind of like a
part a big part of her life is just like
not finishing things like not cleaning
her house I don't know where you get
that in Ken
for more than three decades
[Music]
if I tried it seriously impressive
where's the new stuff that she buys
there yeah
I got a good deal
oh she gets more trash because she needs
more trash to climb up on the other
trash
the wall oh my God now I have the
context now now I'm ready for what's
about to take place
she's hiding on the other side of it
right now he's got a wizard stick
to protect himself
I can smell it through the mouth
I would want glasses like goggles
oh it is
oh my God
fireplace this looks like a really
really really really really cool horror
game setting
so you're playing the horror game like
the jump scares like you know a hands
reaches out the trash yeah yeah exactly
you gotta like dig through all the trash
you never yeah you never expect from the
uh From Below it's almost down in the
hallway somewhere Now You're vulnerable
anywhere in this place
what the suit that is a wizard staff
what the is he doing with that
magic Missile
holy cow dude have you seen any hoarder
this bad
no I have not how do you get through
there where does that even go you can
adopt through that one you know that's
the part of the horror game where like
the point of no return yeah
[Laughter]
oh that inside the house is just totally
disgusting the smell is the part that
you just can't explain I thought a lot
of the stuff would have been cleaned out
by Michelle she's had a lot of time to
get to it they thought that she would
clean it
we came over
oh not the bathroom uh
where's the toilet just rat poop in
there that water hasn't been working
that Crab Pot we talked about earlier
that was probably right you know yeah
probably all right
thank you
polishing into the microwave maybe
oh my God she has a microwave in her
bathroom why why why
this is the only place she can get to
the outlet
she's been making hot cocoa too oh maybe
this is after she cleaned it just hit me
[Laughter]
bless our home
ah
our immune system must just be like gone
like level you think there's anything
like salvageable in here you know how
like people buy storage space to get a
bargain
come on all right you guys want to place
your bets and see if you can think of
this trash and find something actually
worth something there was that one roll
of toilet paper in this room which is
questionable do you think the new owner
that they sell to gets to know like what
the state of this house was no way no
right oh my God a rat for all of them
bites me let me see in the back
oh man I was really scared the whole
time a rat might show up and fight me
oh God if I squat over here I sure hope
not a rad what comes or bites me are you
getting this you're getting a shot at me
hey cameraman if you stand squat down
right here and I'll
see I hope the cameraman doesn't fight
me in the butt
intense oh God they got it they caught
one
[Music]
popping out from every corner and from
from sitting on them so I just I had to
get out of there oh my God this is the
backyard
after witnessing the conditions at the
house the Gaul Brothers realize that if
they have any chance of getting in
return they're brothers are they related
oh the toilet oh so the toilet is she
spared the toilet that was dumb but
apparently they did like help her out I
think they kind of took a loss just to
help her out good so it does have a
little bit of a happy ending you know
what I mean oh okay yeah good thing the
camera was there though so they did that
you know I don't know I just read it in
the comments I haven't seen more than
that no yeah okay they didn't actually
buy her a house so hopefully she can
just move somewhere else yeah I know
right that's that's the weirdest part to
me is I think they bought the house and
they're like she has to clean the house
not her house anymore why would she
300 000 items in your home become an
epic minimalist throw it all away I
believe I actually believe she had 300
000 items in her house yeah she's the
reason that statistic is so high well
that was really fun to watch ken check
out Ken's Channel he does similar stuff
and uh
subscribe to me check out the nordvpn
promo down in the description and I'll
see you guys next time bye bye can say
bye and money with the camera I I was
waving bye-bye okay